all right and we are live
the last word with lord cognito and
ibontis
on that fresh friday morning campfire
what's going on sir
it's been an interesting week um down
here in the state of texas especially we
have i have been
extremely lucky uh i think my house is
attached to like one of those lucky
power grids that
needs to be on but i have a friend who
is out of power for 72 hours
like finally got power back in his house
yesterday and finally got things heated
up he was in there with like
his wife's dad is like a prepper of all
preppers so
propane tanks and space heaters that
attached to propane tanks and he was
like
trying to like thaws pipes and
everything's and just like the pictures
you're seeing so now
it's been absolutely crazy but shout out
to this game for keeping me slightly
distracted and busy so
but before we do all that um yeah life
happens but we still got a podcast to do
and we've got an awesome guest joining
us so
sir let's uh let's welcome him in yeah
so let's welcome
to the last word episode number 137
and it's a glorious friday we're back in
front of the campfire for some more lou
to shoot a discussion
i'm extremely excited about our special
guest so we gonna get right into it
i want to introduce a lord whose
insightful commentary in addition to his
charitable work throughout the destiny
community
are truly remarkable to watch this
musician
and humorous fps enthusiasts always
remind us
it's not about the beat on your face but
the being on your heart
if you got a bit on your heart damn it
you need to contact the doctor
immediately immediately introducing
the co-host of the planet destiny
podcast and a host of the danfinity
twitch and beardo podcast
the lord of fellow offensive laughter
and the best reaction to receiving eyes
of tomorrow
live on stream
live from indianapolis and making his
debut
at the campfire of the last word
mommy lord danfinity how we doing sir
i'm doing well that was that was quite
the intro thank you so much
i've never felt so honored that's what
we like to do for our guests
you come in we want to make you feel
special that's what we do i do
i was waking up this morning i was like
man i don't know if i don't know how
special i feel today that makes me feel
really special thank you
you don't even need caffeine this
morning you know you just i don't know
just record the sdg that's your club
yeah that's your click
i mean i got my advanced gg but yeah i
got like
got i put on the sweatshirt hey okay
okay okay
okay that's what's up brother now you're
good at cool what you do glad to have
you
first of all how are you doing man how's
those things been going for you
personally
uh personally things have been going
well but like the past like
few months have been real crazy in
stream and in life
and so um yeah doing doing well overall
um pretty pleased with where we are
right now
in destiny and yes yes yes
overall just pretty good nice nice nice
so you know we got a lot of questions
for him east i don't
know you gonna set it off what we got
for the man
i know sometimes we'll be like what is
your gaming history but you got one that
i
have to talk about because i don't see
it on many people's lists
super mario rpg legend of the seven
stars man
that one is special to be as it's
literally probably one of my first out
that in chrono trigger i like mine too
like how give me your story on that game
like why is that on why is that on your
list
i'm curious that is the first rpg i ever
played oh wow
like that we so my gaming history we got
we got a super nes when everybody else
got n64
but you had the same size yeah yeah
the box was the same size so it was for
christmas too
so we're like in 64. mom and dad did it
right
and like they did us they didn't do us
dirty
because the super nintendo has like such
a rich catalog of games
and so like super mario rpg has a
special place in my heart
gino uh marshmallow
yeah but yeah it was it was
the first time that like had
mechanics like just
spaced out fights yes whereas everything
else that i had played
was button matchy like do it in the
moment
so that was it was interesting and i was
like oh man i wish there were more games
like that
yeah turns out there were you're like oh
how
oh how be careful the words you wish for
so oh yeah yeah oh yeah
no but i just i see so few people with
that on on their list but i was like
chrono trigger is good but that was
probably like i don't know the order i
played the two
but that one sticks out of my head
pretty damn high for super nintendo as
well because it's like
i've enjoyed mario forever like mario 3
and super mario brothers and then all of
a sudden you're playing like
this like isometric like you know
rpg leveling him up you're playing next
to like all the different characters you
don't expect to
some of them are like as you said gino
is so unique and just all
like the mechanics of like hit the
button so you do more damage
no it's like that one's i've i have a
special place for certain rpgs because
i've like
never played a final fantasy which i
know is sacrilege okay um
ever yeah i'm getting looks right now i
don't i don't think
i i don't think i finished the final
fantasy but but you've played
i've played yeah i've started them
i've attempted that is one of those
things about like bigger games now
because even me like
i'm about halfway through immortals and
i have to force myself to go back but
then i'm
looking at like outraiders demos coming
and i'm like when am i gonna get back to
that game and i gotta have through it's
just like
it's hard now to not have just like oh i
just wanna play some games and i'm a kid
it's like
no especially as a content creator
anybody who does like whether it's
articles
written podcasting videos whatever at
this point you're like
doing things for fun you're like i feel
like i'm wasting my time
yeah there's only so much time in the
day yeah yeah yeah
that's a good thing yeah for me i was
like oh yeah that's a that's a classic
another one that you had on your list
that i really
as a as a co-op guy i really uh got an
affinity for is you had a
turtles in time man yeah i gotta talk
about that i rarely see that i was a
classic
talk to me about that one that was the
first game that i ever beat
oh wow that's hard too yeah okay
my brother and i my brother's about four
years younger than i am
and then we had my my sisters are all
older
than me like the youngest one is 13
years older than me oh wow so
they were having kids in the midst of it
so my nephews
were kind of like an extra set of
brothers got you because it was the
bracket the age bracket yeah it makes
sense and so we would
that was the game where when they came
over brad and i would start beating it
together
and then ross my my actual brother ross
would start
beating it with me and so uh please
nobody i isolate that
audio but um it was
[Laughter]
it was an awesome game and really fun uh
especially man it's just like coming
from a turtle's
like background talk to him talk to him
yeah turtle
turtles fans here let's go heroes
with some of the cartoon bits and
everything else i loved it it's such a
good game
it was a craze in the indian age like
tmnt was everywhere you remember the
cartoon
the merchandising everything about it
just unique and cool hey
kids stuck to that thing like magnet
like it was just they just had the
perfect combination of weirdness but it
just worked those movies were probably
just about as weird
the movies were probably just about as
weird oh yeah as like the super mario
brothers movie but they were still so
much
better movies too so yeah yeah
so confession time oh i
so the teacher asked us to do show and
tell for kindergarten
and i didn't have anything on the day
because i made special plans with the
teacher so that i could show the behind
the scenes of teenage mutant ninja
turtles too
which i had the vhs for it's about half
an hour long and yes it features vanilla
ice extensively
[Laughter]
what how did you get access to it
i don't i think it was at walmart and
i'm
it it points to me always being the kind
of nerd that's just like i want to
dive in and find out as much as i can
about the things that i love absolutely
i think that was the first important of
things to come
oh my god that's classic classic there
what else you
i mean like you got some
some like bangers in there the fact that
you went atari
snes eventually got to like what
what's what was like the big system did
you get an n64 did you just like jump
into bigger stuff later
so the so we had an atari 2600 that my
brother-in-law gave us
and we played like pac-man and pong and
all sort
like all sorts of stuff on that and then
we got that super nintendo
and that was that was a revelation to
to both of us um i played a lot of
game boy i mowed several
lawns to get a game boy color and uh
yeah like was was really into pokemon
like pokemon red
pokemon yellow huge um and i got pokemon
yellow just because
like even though it was like red and
blue kind of like together
it was just the thought of having
pikachu follow you
around everywhere that was kind of cool
salute that was a huge game yeah huge
game oh my god
and bagel game so there was that and
then
um legend of dragoon i was still mowing
lawns
but i was mowing for my sister for
payment she would let me
like play her playstation down in the
basement
and i purchased legend of dragoon it was
like a 20
greatest hits at toys r us and i
i ran through that guy like that was
that was some of the hardest battles
that i had up to that point that also
fed that rpg addiction
and then uh ended up purchasing a
playstation one
so like when they minimized it oh yes
yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah okay and so played like metal
gear solid
oh on that even though my parents
probably
wouldn't have been too happy about that
uh it's okay that's fine now
yeah it's fine so uh statute of
limitation
yeah and then
oh see that right there struck a chord
he's like
yeah and then uh yeah like playstation 2
i skipped playstation 3
and then got a playstation 4 after like
finding destiny
so okay yeah yes ps4 is the way
the way the way to do it uh yeah
no seriously about like you said game
boy though and it brought me back i
gotta ask if anybody in chat or any of
you guys know there was like and i
looked i had to look it up there was a
simpsons like camp game and i had to
look it up to know what it was and it's
like
um bart simpson's escaped from camp
deadly or something like that night you
said game boy i was like
i remember like working it was of course
like the black and green or whatever
it was like the crazy old g one but i
was like i remember spending too much
time on that ridiculous game and when
you said you finally beat a game i was
like
that's so that's like one that like i
don't know if i ever beat but it's like
there's a couple of those game boy games
that wrote was just too damn hard there
was
one called zuul that i've been reminded
of
recently because ben pak formerly of
giant bomb
posted about it on twitter and i was
like i have not thought of zuul
in so long you were like this alien
ninja
and it just
i i don't i don't know how many times i
went up against it
but i always failed i continually got
back it's
just such a weird game nice
yeah there's a mess i'm sorry if you
guys hear my dogs i don't know if you do
i can hear them so i am now
you'll hear them probably when i talk
because otherwise it's probably low
enough it cuts them out but apparently
they're playing right now so
yeah chad knows what he's talking about
zul ninja from the ninth dimension
there you go no doubt shout out to farm
walk he remembers
yeah the villain ghostbusters that
sounds right too
so yeah apparently we're just dating
ourselves how old are you guys
old oh yeah too old
old enough to remember pre-internet yeah
dial-up
oh yeah who picked up the phone
you see i'm online damn oh that's when
you shot the aol discs you had to get
the second oh they
all say it was up to like 250 more hours
than you could actually have in a month
like
i just live i
[Music]
it took me four hours to load this page
fax thanks
for that image to load oh yeah shout out
to earthlink
netscape all the old browsers and
all the all the other modems man that
was the back of the day man
so tremendous history of course you know
for the gaming but um
as far as like now you know obviously
this game we like here
you know what i'm saying like the the
whole introduction to it like
what started that whole craze
um so i remember seeing i think
there was a commercial like a commercial
or something on hulu
or something along those lines it was
either either a commercial on hulu or
like on youtube
that had destiny i'd never played halo i
somehow skipped that and
a lot of that lately you notice yeah
yeah i think like we're on a four guest
streak
of destiny fans who are like yeah i
never played halo but
that is interesting to me continue cause
i'll be hey look i just very
yeah that works but i've like i can't
say i've like
finished all of them or anything i've
probably would you play but a lot of
people play
yeah they have not played but they heard
about destiny
and obviously knew that bungie made it
but that is interesting
yeah it was it was definitely like name
recognition and bungie i was like
well i'm not going to jump into like
halo 3
right like and so why don't i start with
their new
their new thing their new [ __ ] and so um
the library that i was working at at the
time rented out video games
um on console and so you could have them
for a week
um and i
picked it i picked up on playstation 3.
i didn't own a playstation 3 my roommate
did at the time
and so i used
he allowed me to use his playstation to
play
through i think i got to like
i think i got to venus and then had to
take it back
but i didn't and ended up getting late
fees on it
oh of course yeah you're like i'm
keeping this i'm not done
oh yeah yeah and then um i don't know it
was
like just there was something about it
that
like tickled my fancy and so
i ended up when he moved out
i ended up purchasing a playstation 4.
this is after the first s irrelevant
so i missed the first srl completely
um oh sad at that time i joined a dad's
a destiny
plan i'm not a dad but i was a musician
and i was like these guys understand
time constraints
yes yeah and boundaries
so i i joined up with uh
it was uh what was it forget the name of
the clan
oh my god uh oh it was high command dod
high command
oh my god i wasn't never there they were
about to disown you yeah
i was about to clip this so
so i joined up with them and like
became an admin for them and like a rage
sherpa in some
to some degree by taking king time and
yeah it's just always stuck with me now
you stay
i just want to kind of pressure you a
little bit you said
you know it definitely you rented it
those late fees definitely you know
kicked in because you had enjoyed
yourself a dollar a day what what
shout out to the dollar they left what
like what was it
as far as like if you could if you could
try to nail like what
was it specifically was it just because
you you're into a space game was it like
the gun mechanics like was it what was
the hook that said yo i just can't stop
playing it
it was it was the intrigue really like
because of the fact that there was no
story
yeah i mean that kind of plays into it a
little bit but
we didn't know that that's part of the
injury there's so much mystery and
you're like where's the
end of the mystery yeah where's the end
of the mystery and you're like oh is it
in the vault of glass
and so i i didn't have a mic at the time
but i spent
six hours with a raid team from uh the
100. io
and they i was able to hear them they
weren't able to hear me
i was going to ask you that when i saw
your back yeah i was like how is this
possible
so that's why it took six hours is
because
we're using like we're using the um
the playstation like chat mm-hmm in
order
they're like hey do you understand this
and like sometimes i'd be able to like
just not up and down or no
and then if they i needed to describe
more in depth what i was doing
i would have to type it out to them okay
and it was wow
like i think people this is a
playstation
messaging app on your phone
playstation party no they'd be like a
playstation party probably and you're
typing in the chat at the party i would
imagine he's breaking immersion
in game oh yeah okay i got you wow okay
wow playstation button
type type it out with yeah i'm using
this to type
it's not a good system
they like they had infinite patience
with me
yeah so that's pretty good that was yeah
we got we got through it
and there's a picture from i think my
old um
my old instagram my instagram previous
where it's just like me after the raid i
was like do they all
take six hours
first time yes yes they do yeah so i
don't know it was
like that
not knowing what the story was and kind
of going in deeper and deeper
and then finding that that had lore
behind it
that wasn't in the game and then and
then also like meeting up with people
and kind of joining
it was my first community that i joined
outside of like a music community
outside of like a local music scene
so it was very special to me
nice i've actually seen that going
around on
twitter and i don't remember the exact
wording i started playing destiny and
didn't know
i'd have like the friendships have you
guys seen that one going around twitter
no yeah it was like even luke like even
said something
like and it's it's uh something like the
why
i actually did one yeah yeah he was like
the y and he's like because of
destiny i met strangers that turned into
friendships that was the one
and you said that it's like we've met
communities people you play with
remember
you remember the people you experience
those moments with as well it's
you know destiny has done yeah sometimes
english nothing else has
ever done yeah and and to add on to what
you said he
also i thought was a nice touch was when
remember when d2 launched
when they did those reflective memories
of d1
with your time stamps and the fire teams
you did them with
and for many people it was very
emotional because i know for me
personally
you know we had lost a friend shout out
rest in peace uh lord whiskey
and he was part of my raid team for
taking for kingsville
and it showed all the gamer tags all the
people the day you did it you know what
i'm saying that kind of thing every
important
milestone and i thought that was a
really
cool homage a very classy take you know
to kind of bring in the destiny too
and uh yeah shout out to that so yeah i
did i did see the um
the the the why as far as why people are
into it i actually fill one out
myself back to our esteemed guest
which guy no um so how did you transfer
from obviously like dad's a destiny
doing a little bit of sharpening there
and now you're like
content and writing and like part of all
these like
obviously you know pieces of the
community especially like planet destiny
and destiny tracker
you've yeah become pieces of those and
like how did how did it get into it and
how's it been so far
so like i did i didn't think that i'd
start streaming in earnest ever like
i i i kind of started around dod time
i would stream on sundays and just
primarily
to the dod group that i was in
because if like what people wanted
raid and raid often so it was like okay
this is a way to teach mechanics and
also show the good time to
the rest of the group and but i didn't
start
streaming in earnest until maybe like
september 2016
on my channel and i was saying i quit
smoking that day
and then well thank you um and then
a few months later duba was doing
something
and he needed bodies for like a video or
something like that
so he he put out a call and
i kind of knew him from um the
guardian radio podcast back in the day
legends legends yeah
so like i knew i knew him from that
and then ended up being in that video
that same day i had an interview with
destiny tracker with jay from
destiny tracker ended up joining there
for a while
and was on their podcast on that team
ended up like transitioning out of that
shortly around d2
and then joined planet destiny
2018. resume looking dick right now
just kind of floated all over the place
with me who's gonna take me i'll go here
here
here all right i'm just going to be
creative come on
i just like making stuff and so like
if even if it isn't affiliated with like
a brand
or something i'd still be making things
but
i've been insanely lucky with
who i've gotten to work with uh in my
time
so it's it's been it's been a really
wonderful journey it feels longer than
it actually has been
and uh yeah man i don't know it's it's
it's been a lot of fun
no i will say anything anybody who's
done
content like you're like you think of
like how long have i been doing this and
you're like oh that's all
and yeah when you said it feels longer
than it has been i can
definitely empathize with that and
people ask me how long have you been
doing that i have to think because like
i mean every day you feel like you're
never doing enough so it's like it
always feels
longer yeah by the time you get around
to doing it so no i just had to
had to chime and i was like 100 agree oh
that's real that's real man that's
really cool and i just love
like i said one thing i like about your
content
as a person who raids you know just
looking at your sherpa
and stuff and i think that's a that's an
art shout out to my boy
back back from the dead who's in there
he's one of our sherpas from my lord
podcast and on our destiny clan
but like i think like it takes a certain
disposition to be a good sherpa in my
opinion especially for raid
because you know obviously you know the
mechanics and stuff like that but i like
the way you talk
to people okay hey you gonna do this
okay you guys just gonna clear ads
i'm gonna shoot this scanner thing and
then you're gonna do this i'm gonna
operate like
this so people don't realize there's a
way to talk to people
so that because it's a very intimidating
process for
a new person and i think we don't
celebrate our sherpas enough
so it's like i wanted to salute you on
that because i i was listening i was
like let me see how he sure but
let me see what he doing you know but it
was really cool and you make it fun and
and help everybody out and then like i
said that that you know satisfaction
when the raid is complete they get their
first
you know clear and it's like it's a big
deal man so salute to you on that for
sure yeah
that's been i i've been told that i'm
incredibly patient
and that is a blessing and a curse i
don't know it's
it's required yeah and so
i don't know and through all of this you
you learn you learn from different
people
and you just you you end up taking that
and packaging it in a way that is
understandable to people
that's like the best way that you can um
if you can add some humor into it i feel
like people um
understand that more like uh during last
wish
uh the ogre section um i
usually call that the taken bonds
because two hit two hits is just right
but if you take any more than that
it's it's a big big rip little buddy
there you go
all right you going going baby
go ahead and have to mark this podcast
in the uh youtube algorithms there
all right all right yeah the opinions of
the infinity do not necessarily
we all have histories
i was like we gave up one thing for
another one of
this shout out to the algorithm
and the algorithm is like you're good
you're good you're good
like you just have to you have to make
it palatable so that people
understand what what they're doing what
the end goal
is and how to get there and so
that's that's always been my kind of
goal
but you know to varying degrees of
of uh completion
success yeah so you know sometimes you
got to take them to a section at a time
you know
yeah you know sometimes like okay this
is this is where we at tonight
you know that kind of thing and then you
know based on the skill levels and stuff
like that someone oh shout out to pom
leeto savage
he said and make sure to ask him how he
got his nickname
dan arkey
they taught me the uh way that you can
reset the balls during scourge of the
past
in the final section yeah don't don't
flip that one out of context either
yeah reset the balls but we're good
don't get it don't get us destiny does
this to us
oh i know taking things the worst don't
worry
oh yeah especially yeah yeah
yeah jump puzzles
they taught me how to do that and with
that information like
pablito and i i want to say that he and
i ran
probably 35 people through
through the last section together
what you got that i know what you're
talking about once we got that down we
and during season of the arrivals we
helped 102 guardians
get uh anarchy that's into the like on
stream i
a buddy of mine uh mr good bites helped
me
make this uh bar that raised every time
like i was able to add and subtract from
it so every time an anarchy got added on
it just went up higher until like we
filled it
nice and it got down to the wire on the
last possible day
last possible sunday we could help
people do it
and we i think we were at like 97 and it
was it was getting like
it was looking like maybe it wasn't
going to happen and then we had like
five drop
later on in the day nice
awesome oh yeah oh yeah i remember that
i actually
know exactly what you're talking about
it was right around you know the end of
the previous season
and then increase the the the rate for
that you could just
run it continuously and i was in the
same boat
i wasn't in the same boat as far as you
you know running this amazing
stream helping the community but i was
part of a group that was
shout out to wilhelm scream he was down
with it um a couple others and they knew
the strat that you're talking about
because to be honest you eat i gave up i
was like i'm never gonna get
back oh nice i got mine around the same
time i had help to get mine and a couple
people were like are we going to do this
a couple times bam like
i was lucky enough to get mine pretty
quick and then i helped my brother get
his
yo it it was it was so crazy i'm
literally calling like yo
i'm calling people you better get in
i'm driving for work right now hold your
spot cause i just got mine so it was
like share the love we got to try to get
this thing because to be honest i've
been so
unlucky since um thousand voices of ever
getting those type of drops
i never i was like never going to happen
so what i got was like yes my first kind
of rare
ray dropping that so i get you you know
on that big time
and it was unknown whether you'd be able
to earn it after beyond light
correct so and with it being one of the
best like
dps guns in the game and probably i
would consider it the yeller horn of
destiny 2 in summer cards when it comes
to like
raid teams i mean it's been it's been
required or highly used for a long time
yeah yeah so like
to the point of like okay people need
this
going forward and like we're just gonna
help people to get it and so pablito
like
um he he helped he helped
me learn the mechanic we did like the
first 35 together and then like you know
just
life happens so but yeah he's
he's my dude shout out to pablo though
uh no like not too much else at this
point i know
i wanted to kind of touch on just the
way you handle your twitch channel
is actually a really really cool thing
that you do i was kind of curious wanted
to
let you explain how you handle your
twitch channel and kind of what you
do all of that for so i don't want to
give it too much i'm going to let you
tell it so
okay are you talking about second
helpings yep okay yeah
so uh back when twitch uh decided that
we want you to watch ads all the time
yeah that's fair yeah and then and then
force that
force that on the creator to kind of
make that a thing if
if people wanted to watch for any
duration of time um
i didn't really feel comfortable taking
that money and
so i there's a local charity in town
second helpings they're a food rescue
charity based out of indianapolis
um they rescue food they
feed families in need not only that but
they also
teach culinary skills so that people can
work in a kitchen
like people can get job skills
and learn how to work in a commercial
kitchen and so
last year during 2020
they rescued 2.1 million pounds of food
just in central like indiana and uh
they opened up like several different um
satellite kitchens with a few local
restaurants
and just really made a huge impact on
the community so anytime you watch ads
in my stream that money goes to second
helpings that's awesome that is
that's awesome and i love the second
part the the culinary skill
also like that is very unique very cool
to kind of equip people with that skill
set so they could try to
employ themselves with you know that
technique yeah so like
i think so the the goal last year was to
do five thousand dollars
it turns out ad revenue is not that much
but what um this year this year i'm
planning a few things
a few charity fundraisers
uh to try to reach that because i would
really like to sponsor a class
like i think it's a it's like a 10 week
course
10 to 12 week course and that's 5 000
and that helps i think five to seven
people
that's awesome so brother man you're
doing it man
very very cool very admirable i love how
you always cut it
and it mixed with a lot of charitable
efforts and stuff like in the community
seem to be always being involved in
that needs to be commended because we
definitely don't see we need to see more
of it you know what i'm saying as far as
in the community itself so yeah salute
to you for that
my man that infinity oh i got to ask him
this so it's got to be
your name because of divinity
like what what's the whole day and
feeling we got to break it down all
right like it's so it was so early
before
all like like break that down why
infinity
so my name is dan my last name is not
finity
i was thinking of gamer names and
my my buddy uh to infinity and beyond
yeah my my buddy kurt his name was like
cj updike
and like like that's that's his name
like his name is card updike
and so uh when
we went when i was looking through i was
like i'm not gonna put my last name out
there
i don't know like people could find it
definitely but like
i don't know i've been in high school
yeah i thought of i thought of um
it would be real weird if there were
like infinite amounts of me
or like infinite versions of me out in
the universe
because i have a feeling that would
probably be the same uh
all the way around and uh
so like i was like ah danfinity and i
was able to get it on twitch so i was
like hey
awesome sweet and then uh you go to
twitter and everywhere else
and like a thirteen-year-old
claim it everywhere yeah did you have it
on stadium too
did you get that one i did get it on
stadium
should have been an easy process yeah
that was that was an easy one
they pretty much they almost sold me
half the company but i was like
um it's like you had to get that early
package to make sure and like claim your
name first right yeah yeah yeah
because you know
clearly yeah yeah you had to get a whole
the whole thing but um
yeah other than that all my socials are
the day infinity
where the eyes are l's because this
one person has gotten it and they said
it's been weird to watch them grow up
stephen when they they got their name i
feel you on that
well that's about that's about all i got
but of course this week we have been
busy
as we get into bungie being like hey
week two
bam yeah bungie
here's stuff to do
so we log in we get the new battleground
start in the quest
i log in first and the first thing i saw
is the inside of the tank because i
glitched in in a battleground yes i saw
your tweet
i literally did i loaded into a
battleground it was part done first
thing i do when i
like load in i'm stuck dying over and
over
facing a door with a red light on my
head and i'm just like dying
and dying i'm like where am i but it
also looks weird i'm like
am i so i hugged on for a little bit i
kept dying and they like
progressed until like the boss bar
appeared and i was like oh
and then i could run back and forth
inside the tank i wasn't dead i wasn't
stuck dead and i was like
so i have pictures inside like the
infantry area now like you can see the
mechanical part of the tank up top
running
so i do that i'm like oh this is kind of
cool and i go to tweet that i'm like
wait a minute this is not big news
because something else happened
somebody's like go here so
i want to let dan have you pl i know
you've played it right
yes i've gone through it twice yep um so
i want to kind of get your take on it
first
because they've heard what i hoped this
was
on the podcast previously so i want you
to kind of
give give a lowdown of what we what we
experienced when we walked in
so we you go in you well
you go into the nightfall you pick up
you you pick up the transponder piece
and then you're you're you're told to go
to this derelict ship
who tells you uh i believe it is
it's osiris right well zavala zavala
anyways will you talk to zavala
about it pay attention well you talk to
us of all about it but i feel like
osiris is involved too so they're both
there okay
yeah he's he's definitely the one giving
the commands when once you're on the
ship oh well so osiris is giving a play
by but he's
yeah yeah okay yeah he's here it's good
this is good i like this
and so like you get on you get onto the
ship there's a little bit of jumping
puzzle there's a little bit of jumping
puzzle
oh and then there's so have you ever
played control
a little very okay so
you you reach this door that you
butt up against it and you start burning
and you're like ah why am i
why how how do i get past this and then
you see these little spores
off the side and they take damage and
once you hit them
i think you get aggro ogre or something
like that yeah it's like eager gore or
something like that
yeah igor and once you have that buff
you can pass through the door the fungal
door
and you're able to progress through
there's there's various
spaces with the spore doors and and the
uh in switches
and you make your way through and it
just keeps getting creepier and creepier
and you're not
facing anything you're just kind of
wandering around this empty space
and it's a horror space now until the
screams show up
it is probably the most effective use of
the scorn
in destiny yeah it's
it it completely changes how i looked at
them as
as a species
and yeah so like the further you get in
like there's
there's different there's a trash
compactor scene
and all sorts of stuff oh that is so
perfect
it was it it when you drop down in here
there you're like is that
a trash oh this is a trash compactor oh
the walls are coming in
and we died once oh i died multiple
times my first time
well i figured it out like one time my
second time through
i died like six times trying to find the
last little guy and then i was like
then i kind of figured out like get the
little bit of vertical and you were fine
but
no the trash compactor was fantastic
somebody in my chat was like
i wish there was something else in the
trash compactor with you though just to
give you a little bit
of you want to get out yeah but i'm
gonna i'm gonna have to stop you though
because
you skipped you said hey little jumping
puzzle
yeah you do the first exterior jumping
puzzle and then the audio team just
crashes it out of the absolute park
really oh god what's that what my boy
scott
team did oh well i had probably more
sound design not composing
okay uh i mean there's probably good
music in the background but that's not
as much as what you noticed the ominous
nature when i said i was like
hey i wonder if this is gonna be like
alien isolation
one hun alien isolation dead space
like as he said you don't see anything
for the longest time
that doesn't mean in certain rooms you
get in
like yeah oh yeah like ominous growling
shaking like huge footstep stomps yeah
like they set the tone the lighting
little like
flashes of like little flickers of
things and like go around a corridor and
just the volumetric lighting they have
and the little flickers no
you walk it you're like oh what's this
you kind of see a little bit and you go
around the outside
they set the tone from like the first
air vent and they know oh
it's it's quite a it's quite awesome
and like so you keep progressing you you
start facing more and more score and as
you go on
you end up in a hangar where you're
facing
a ton of enemies like just a huge volume
of enemies like
give me volume comparison like um zero
hour
end level of enemies um
i would say a little bit more or at
least like more tanky enemies
well tanky okay yeah they got some heft
and then yeah you got
you got a good mix that comes through
because they come in like waves and you
still got wedge of screams jumping at
you all over the place yeah they might
you're like oh i'm kind of safe no i'm
not like
it also feels like every enemy you face
is a red sword
regardless of your power level yeah you
are wow yeah you're under leveled like
the whole time
oh wow yeah okay
and so you get to this hangar and you
see a
menagerie ship the one of the ships that
you were able to earn from the menagerie
and you get these the weirdest part for
me
was like you get these kind of like
little transponder
um messages from
from characters that you know have
passed
yeah or like or have supposedly passed
like the first time
i got in have we know yeah yeah
and like the first time i got in it was
callous
that's the weirdest one of all right
yeah because it's
it's thought that he went to commune
with the darkness but we don't know how
that turned out right
and so the like he came through and he's
like
guard doesn't appreciate like something
like that
yeah they all say something dark because
i've had and i wish
i have them somewhere but it's like i've
had seguira
mm-hmm i've had kids
back up this is major things
that's why no no that's what i'm saying
like these are like
it's when you get done with the hanger
fight and it's a jump
to outside platforms each one of those
characters
says something kind of as he said like
kind of muffled kind of dark
and but it's a quote that you've heard
from them yeah okay okay okay okay
and i'm like ah it's so weird that it's
coming so yeah one was sigur because i
played through this thing like four or
five times
okay sagira kade
that i know i don't know if there's any
more yeah
i don't i don't know either my my two
playthroughs i got kallus
and i got kade so it's randomized
yeah kind of like last wish oh
okay got you got you okay
and so yeah you you progress through
there
there's a there's a few more puzzles
there's a few more enemies that you face
and then you get to the boss um
and that boss room mechanic is really
cool um
he's got like um just a cat of nine
tails of fire
yeah and like
you you face him for a little bit and
then he just disappears
and you see there are grates on the
floor that are all covered red
okay so you know there
you get waves of adds wave waves of ads
waves of ads
there's three switches in that room and
each one
flushes a section of
the the basement so once you've flushed
all three
then it's safe to go downstairs and
that's where you see him and it has
huge sunless cell like feelings around
it it's it's a little more well lit
yeah okay okay you you go down there
he's chunked into three sections of
health you do one
one third and then it's time to go back
up you do the whole
you repeat the whole thing over again
gotcha
after that fight you leave and you print
you go to the helm of the ship
and there is a guardian strung up by the
fungal
like impaled
oh it's it's it's pretty gnarly for
destiny
the lore is so much worse than what it
looks like um
he went through yeah oh so much that's
awesome that's
that's the dead man's tail yeah it's
it's
reveal the gun is revealed you take it
before anybody else can get it
and then go back to zval and claim your
prize so during this
fight or leading up to it and after
what's what's osiris is zavala saying
like while you're in there like
what's the commentary like for the most
part like what's the like the theme of
just like guardian transmission like a
guardian
you know this person fallen or is it
your ghost just communicating
making sense of what has happened mostly
osiris talking to you about what he's
figuring out kind of from scans and
stuff as you go through
there's an unknown signal there's
another life form aboard
basically there's a hunter i'm probably
going to butcher the name because i know
new red's got it in there catabasis
k-a-t-a-b-a-s-i-s um he said he worked
for callus securing things we know we
the previous piece of like hunter arms
or whatever is says like
hey go and try and pick up as many scorn
as you can
um and the boss is communion with the
darkness or something like that is like
i forget the boss's name but it's
something communion with the darkness
and basically like
when it finally came to the end i think
new red said it earlier and he'll have
to correct me
the way it finally ended up going down
is the hunter like with kind of his
final breaths before he knew
ended up shooting his own ghost
so he didn't have to stay and like
because he was in starvation kind of
resting him he knew it was stuck
like it was going downhill and he ended
up like
basically ending it for both of them
because of what they were going through
oh wow that's crazy so yeah it got
really really dark
that's that's crazy it's yeah locust
that's
it for teams of communion
of communion was like boss named locus
of communion so i was like
okay yeah destiny horror
it's pretty rad and then once you run it
again i think it took us 40 minutes
the first time just because we were
exploring everything oh yeah but the
next time i think it took it's like 20
maybe
maybe 25 yeah but uh
after you after that first run you're
able to get a
randomized version of dead man's tail
which is the second
exotic they've done that too yes this is
becoming a trend
about a month yes
yes yes now supposedly there is
something out there from dmg and i
haven't seen it but i've heard it said
that um basically states this is not
something they're going to do
all the time okay for the randomized
exotics because that was one of those
things i literally wondered about too
it's like
as soon as you see the question mark on
it the first time just like hawkmoon was
like
is this like the thing now
and it's supposedly not so
that's one of those things that's like
kind of good to
hear because like i like the idea on a
cut like hawkmoon was random
like you know which bullet's going to do
the damage and they move the random to
it i was like all right
i kind of see what you did there there
right and that makes sense
but i was like the other piece i've
heard kind of her described is like how
do people how do you make people engage
with like
you know they spend time on the content
supposed to get the gun and bail
how do you have people engage with it
more and
again it makes sense right how are you
how are you i know either like attention
sometimes
like are you okay with that or are you
anti-random role if it's not
done often okay like that's kind of
and i heard and i hadn't seen that and
i'm literally looking through trying to
find where it's at but i've heard
somebody say that dmg like confirmed
somewhere that this is not gonna be like
a trend like these two and you know
if it's like maybe one a year max like
i'd be okay like if it's like
hey here's a mission and exotic we spend
some time on
and you know how they mess with the
tweaks of how it's going to go i get it
um part of me though is like it
works on these two specifically
because well they're both kinetics
they're both
like they're not
crazy guns they're not like laser beams
or
you know triple arrow explosion bows and
stuff they're
tickles they're like kinetic text
mechanica
they're kinetic weapons they're pretty
clean when it comes to bullet fire
situation
so i was like i get the idea where
you're going for like hey you know
different perks for stability and range
makes sense as opposed to
i need a gun that shoots eight rockets
out of the eyes of tomorrow like there's
a difference in that
there's a difference in feel of what
those do so it makes sense where like
but again it's like is and that's why i
was like i hope it's not a common thing
because i don't want all of the weapons
that like come from these missions
to be like is it always just going to be
a kinetic pulse or
fill in the blank like you know i get i
get
the type you know as far as the the slot
but i guess like i said my question is
let's just say you know it was like hey
they wanted to do it with another energy
weapon or what do you call a weapon
like your main thing is you just don't
want to see it too often you have a lot
of space between this
as opposed to all of our exotic
acquisition being
randomized so that your you know version
of said gun is always different than my
version kind of thing mm-hmm yeah well
what about you i was just gonna say the
other piece of that is because
collections
don't you can't again how long do these
last chance
yeah you can't save it and if you if
these last for a quote year
during all the things we get in year
four come with queen and somebody's like
hey what's hawkmoon well it's an exotic
theoretically we're still gonna have
but if somebody can't go pull a random
roll from collections just because they
go get even though like
spoils of war or whatever yeah that's a
different problem
so that's a whole bridge they have to
fix before these things go away
yeah it also introduces an interest
they've already said that exotics aren't
getting sunset
or they have no plans to sunset them for
now yeah
i was like i'm waiting for that bomb
i'm slowly bracing i think they're up to
something
if you keep doing it if you keep adding
random roles on exotics
like that then creates the argument for
sunsetting them
right to be they're artificially
creating the right argument for it
and that's my that's why i asked you
guys this question because
first thank y'all for the um the the
whole walk through the quest that sounds
amazing i can't wait to do it you guys
definitely
you you laced that up nice guy got me in
the mold of the
oh bob i was scared i was okay screw
okay it's gonna be crazy
but um just just take it all in the
first time you play yeah
for sure yeah for sure oh i love what
this you said osiris is competent
it's a goal here's the question
will you try will you solo it i you know
what's funny
i've turned into you lately
like i don't know where this happened
and i'm just like i don't
know like i've gotten to this new thing
when new content
especially story story-driven i don't
want
anybody in my party chat i don't want to
hear you talking
shut up and i'm offline because i want
to
focus on what's being said especially
now that they're doing more
narrative and voice this is the most
voice over work
that they've done that's why i am so
team of the chosen i'm team season of
the chosen like
this is the content i want for me
like i love devil's lair i love that
quest with those guys talking
about the banter and the moon made of
cheese and shacks are singing like i
love learning more about these
characters so
this kind of stuff it's all about the
solo for me because
i want to hear like just listening to
you know who had me laughing
it was saladin in the crow going at it
after a battleground
and he was like he said so
what's called was called of sun and crow
like you're inexperienced
you know what i'm saying but crow says
something to him
that was borderline disrespectful but it
was true
and i was just like yeah cause he was
like oh he's again cause you gotta learn
and this is your problem
and this that and crow was like so yeah
so when the red wall popped off
when all the guardians where was you at
hey did he cut the communication
i was like oh they get mad at each other
like i'm
like you gotta mind the holiday like
this is the destiny story content
i live for so yeah i i have a strict
rule now
unless you're going to be in the party
and and quiet
and listening you are not allowed in my
story session for this time
i 100 get that too because like there
are times when somebody be like
they might be half a mission ahead
skipping through stuff and i'm sitting
there like
looking around wanting to take this
thing i shot this thing
what's this thing new yeah yeah exactly
exactly
you're like just just dance like just
just be quiet
take it slow go through it enjoy but
yeah for you i honestly would say
like if you want to know the puzzles you
can like peek i've got my guide like
step by step
just to experience like yeah just turn
your sound up put your headphones on
turn the room
lights off and just enjoy it
oh well definitely i did find the tweet
so i was like i saw drewski was like not
a fan of a continued trend of random
exotic roles
dmg replies back thanks for the feedback
team isn't planning to do this for all
exotics moving forward
hawkmoon was the first but more could
see this in the future it's a fun new
tool in the toolbox but may not be seen
again for a while
that was kind of what i was hoping to
hear and that was actually
kind of the day it dropped anyway so
absolutely
interesting what's up there yeah i i
just like
either for me they're not they're not
also not adding
super powerful perks on these yes
correct
they're definitely god rolls of them but
not super powerful
correct the point of breaking the game
correct um
i don't know it's there's that thought
for me or like
if they were to add an extra rarity
of exotic even that was kind of bonkers
i'd
uh kind of be into that but i don't know
it's definitely like those rumored like
black weapons or whatever
oh yeah yeah i want another tier at some
point
or maybe that's destiny three but i mean
we've talked about set bonuses for armor
has been a thing that i would love to
see
but i mean yeah some other tier of like
the once a year and the only
issue with that is pvp and that's the
problem is
you can do that in a game mostly based
around pve now if they said
here's gun you can go into
do like what if it was a thing where you
have to go do
like certain things in all three
dungeons you collect these pieces and
you take this gun and like
against like combatants of darkness or
whatever like they do that little
modifier so it's okay
and then you make absolutely bonkers
like i would love to see them do that
some way to set something apart for pve
to where it's like
this is broken in pve but you have to do
something ridiculous to earn it
that'd be fun yeah enough fair enough
i can dig it i can do it yeah overall
that mission was
well for one pretty much what i asked
for in the podcast when i saw the
preview it was like
a literally like screenshot of the ship
i was like now it wasn't like a timed
extraction as we thought it might be
but was it a horror mission pretty much
everything else yeah yes
absolutely does part of me wish it
wasn't just the k
the hangman okay
for scoring boss yeah that's your boss
oh okay okay okay yeah so it's like it's
yeah when he yeah he's got the big you
know the hanging thing and he'll mess
you up believe me you got to be careful
fighting him
but i will say it was like that's one of
those moments where i'm like i wish they
would do some
slight modification to some of these
guys to give them a little bit of
uniqueness because
when you get your crota's and your
oryx's they're obvious but sometimes
those like
i just want to see your bosses yeah yeah
i want to see something different
yeah i agree it's he's definitely a boss
where it's just like
you can anarchy him and then run away
and be fine no well my
like i'll tell you mine was a drop
tracking rocket jump up run to the other
side that went back
and it was perfect that's literally all
it did so i had tracking rocket
shoot him if i had enough room because
sometimes you'll hit him and stagger him
i was like cool reload hit him again
jump up he'd run i'd run to the other
side go down and do the little back and
forth
you can you can kite him around a little
bit ah nice nice this is good this is
good well you figure out you kind of
have to because the first time he
smashes you in the head you're like i
don't want near you
shout out to my man black guy he said
yeah that's the same feeling he had when
i saw
yeah we we agree there's been a little
bit of a boss
and mid-tier boss fatigue there yes
uh what the hell is his name zolmak
is that that pit of heresy boss mm-hmm
yeah yeah
yeah like that he's yeah he's
obviously a little over the top but some
variation like a variation
yeah yeah so as opposed to even just
holding a little like as he said the
would you call it a nine-tailed cat yeah
yeah kind of nine tails
out of nine tails like that's the yeah i
mean basically it looks like a spike
flail with fire in it so right fan
enough
yeah what else is going on
uh that was the big one for at least in
game we did get a new battleground on
the cosmodrome so if you guys have gone
through that
it does have some different
functionality that i did
that i did what do you think um i liked
it i liked
i've been liking battlegrounds i i feel
that they're um
different enough like the europa one
the um the other one i forgot was nessus
and now this one and um i liked it
because it felt like yo the cabal
they they they gonna break it to the
house they they tired like that
this is the last stand for them and
they're like we are bringing it
they in there beefing with the the hive
and you getting in the way so
it's just it's just i like how they like
fortified the setup before you go
into the room i like that feeling
um yeah it's just it's chaotic
and it's listen destiny's always good
when you get to shoot stuff endlessly
and just go bonkers with your loadouts
and
there's something about battle and it's
simplistic in its nature but
what i like about it that they don't
that most of their other encounters
don't do
is like they don't a lot like most of
the encounters is everything
is forward-facing this way what i like
about battlegrounds
it's coming from you don't know what's
going on sometimes you got to jump up on
a high place and say okay who's shooting
me
like what's going on you know that kind
of thing and i like it so it's just yeah
i've been i've been loving that
and again my thing is when you do the
little hammer mechanic
again because i'm captain lauren captain
voice over
i love listening so i i sit there and i
open up my little warlock book with my
emote
and i want to hear what they're going to
say now so that's my new thing
about the um the battleground as far as
the um hammer mechanic
i wish like you know i i think as you do
the runes and all that stuff you get
more stuff
out my only thing is i i wish like it
wasn't just one
you know that you you do and then you
know saying like i know they give you
more gold and more
other things but sometimes i wish it was
like you get a little bit more reward
with that i know
i got a lot more stuff so i'm in the
middle with that week seven when you
unlock that thing yeah
like that's part of it yeah that time
getting that crazy
but um i liked when i logged in
cyrus was there kadel was like look you
look like a wise warlock
yeah that was good i liked that she was
like talk to your man like she was like
talk to zavala like
we don't need to do this and he's like
well we beat you before it's like
sounds just like like i don't really see
why we gotta
negotiate with you i guess we can see
you on the battlefield like
it was a dope little standoff i love
these things and then again shout out to
the law team
what's up we um biff got a video out
what's up with crow
but we gotta talk about crow now you on
my bad side
what's up with your man whistling in the
sabbath
remix what's going on i'm like well i'm
sitting there next to the vault and i'm
like did i just hear him
yeah i'm like nah you not
obscene
that's a terrible song it's not my song
now what would be dope it's about theory
for shout out to bite because he's on
the same type of time i'm on
what would be i don't know if they got
the balls to do this what would be dope
there
is if they everybody who's singing this
song
it ends up turning or getting corrupted
by the time we get to which kid
almost like she's got like a seance so
dope
yeah that these people like shot who's
corrupted shacks shacks
um bro crow now clearly yeah you know
i'm just saying zavala is right
i i want now is it is it a situation if
you hear the song also you corrupt it
if you sing it yeah if you sing it right
so i'm very curious
if um you know come which queen
she because she's the master manipulator
if they use that and i think that would
be a
dope twist because the bungie is clearly
hinting this song
has effect and it has ramifications
since the days
of harris talking to drifter about a yo
tell
shax what the hell is he doing like so
they're setting something up
yeah i'm just curious to the extent do
you think they're gonna go to that
extent
of like yo that song is going to be a
problem for people who
sing they mentioned the dominoes at one
point it was either justin truman
or i can't remember who in the viadoc
could have to go back and watch it
maybe noseworthy it was towards the end
it's like they're setting up the
dominoes
for witch queen and that's what like
season 15
the finale whatever that's gonna do
again we have to wonder
now does that seem a little early to do
something that big to
take down a shacks and a zavala maybe
zavala or crow and like
flip people maybe maybe not again i
don't know how
what the pacing of the story is because
with light falls sitting behind it
and we'll get to what's out there in the
future as well right
that's a ques like i um i'm curious the
pace of how quick things go bad
yeah yeah yeah it's gonna be interesting
there's and in birds there's a viral
song
like it can some if it pervades
a population long enough it will change
it will change the tune
so i don't know i would hope that it
would
like we start seeing the the meme go
between different
different players uh well i guess harris
has the song too right
mm-hmm yeah i said she yeah i don't know
the moon made of cheese
boom cheese listen they sitting on
something i'm curious to see the extent
they go with
it that that's what i'm uh but yeah i
mean back to you know your question with
battlegrounds
again i love it man i it's it's been so
enjoyable it's been
you know i miss a miss on a random
tuesday i miss a quest at the beginning
of the season that just let you know
how you know great of a start it's been
the loot chase has been phenomenal
i feel the uh the meta has been in a in
a fantastic place i'm really
you know i just got that grenade
launcher salvo something
salvo i just got one two oh my lord
chain reaction on
acting is nutty by the way just a shout
out to everybody
chain reaction does not pair with
dragonflies yes
shout out to error and a couple other
people who definitely dispel
yeah dispelled that but even without it
it is it's phenomenal i got that
um it's just been a great loot chase i
just got the little
the little james bond p shoot a little
the bill
yeah because i just hit 45 in my season
pass and i just got it too you and i
must be like almost dead on we're like
neck and neck as far as yeah where we at
and like i just love those type of and
that thing's be i got a frenzy
shout out let's shout out the new perks
too yeah these perks
frenzy's fun frenzy's fun you know what
i'm saying
now that i learned the mechanic you know
12 seconds at least in an engagement
yeah it takes a little while to kick on
to kick on you know i'm saying that
thing's good
rocket launchers are amazing right now i
literally it's hard for me to even put
an exotic in this slot that's how good
rocket launcher legendary that what does
it did code willow code dwello
yeah cold dwellers out here i got that
i have that with field prep ambitious
assassin
and with reserves on i have 10 rockets
oh boy
and i'm like that's a lot i have a new
appreciation for ambition assassin i was
not using that correctly yeah that that
perk with those type of guns
and shout out to that gun you got dan i
see industry um that little 750
that 750 kinetic um smg what is it
extraordinary something yeah the new one
oh what is it
one how did you see that i was watching
[Laughter]
extraordinary rendition oh i love that
thing
i love that that is then you got snipers
using barrier now
like you guys are really really strong
really strong now
i gotta say one thing what's up can that
not cost
six six but then come on they got two
though but they got to it's a slip bro
sniper though why cloud strike
how do you use cloud strike with that
not yet busted
cloud strength throw that in the
nightfall where these devils live
it is busted i literally oh you're
probably exploring stuff left and right
yeah
any fallen who want to chill next to
each other out of here
when when sepex is floating around three
double shots and then that that super
cloud that does the extra
oh wow cloud strike is busted with that
thing that's why i caught six
it's just ah it's so frustrating like
it's just like i don't know i was like
why is it after even if it was like
three three not six that's like more
than half of your arms
just to break the barrier like again the
functionality by the way this does prove
as now remember when we were like hey
should exotics be able to use barriers
by the way yeah
yeah they should yeah yes you know what
else is nice i need to bust
out dust or for a good old huckleberry
there huh for the smg
yeah only thing for smg's and overload
i'm
yeah your proximity to be kind of
accurate and then get the sustained
shot like the bow is just like pink yeah
and it's just the bow for like overload
is the way to go like you can do grenade
you can do sword you can do both like
this
number four on that list yeah you know
you're right i forgot about it it's
trinity ghoul
oh my god trinity ghoul is so good
wonderful
it's wonderful i didn't i did a exotic i
did a guide to do the last sector
like yesterday i think and somebody's
like what about trinity goal is like
damn it i forgot yeah because it's all
arc
uh shield harpies running around uh
perdition so if your card
comes up oh god trinity goal would be
amazing cool yeah
and you don't like you kill one thing
you get that chain reaction
if you hit the floor yeah you don't have
to aim
much yeah but yeah it's just a full draw
full draw and then just one pop on and
the nice thing is like you can pair that
with the grenade to have the backup
damage
or use that first and hit him if you
need to the smg is just unreliable it's
not like
hold the hand cannon or pulse rifle and
like aim yeah and then it loads like you
just have the sustained fire ones i'm
just not a fan
because overloads are already the most
finicky in the first place
yeah they're doing the teleporting and
then like getting them have their health
back health back
so fast so annoying i agree i agree
but yeah yeah i mean what about you guys
as far as like you know
i know i've been raving and ran right
how are you guys feeling i got a little
i got a little and i buy a little i mean
a butt load of help this weekend
yeah i i was lucky enough uh aries shout
out to aries
dragged me into trials what
you graced the legend
yes now i will honestly tell you
i got you i got the messenger they took
me through a three card
so i did that in the bounty and then a
five and then had enough tokens my i got
two that had celerity and zen moment so
two of them were
awful my last one outlaw desperado
because so i posted that and some people
are like oh i'm not a content creator
i'll never get to like play and i was
like believe me
knowing people helps to get to play with
certain people i get that but i will
honestly say like
you can listen to firing range listen to
cammy talk and like his
the science and the way he plays but two
for one
ultra nice guy like cannot like when you
play with them the way they're like
kind of giving you tips on what to do
the way they'll play
uh gave me feedback in the interest of
stuff that i can work on but
generally like watching watching people
being in like you can watch on the other
side and somebody to destroy and be like
i can't learn that much
but being on their team and watching
where they go
how they play and seeing like just
seeing some of the shots that they hit
but also watching them move for one
feeling like my feet are stuck in cement
yes cause i'm dude mobility is like one
of the biggest things for high skilled
players and that's just like
it's so proved when you're on the team
and you're like
well i just lost that track meet but
anyway but like
but just like watching and listening and
learning kind of seeing what they do and
in a certain situation be like okay
we're gonna switch and completely shift
our play style this way on the fly
it's very it's very cool to watch
somebody like
that skill level play because it goes to
show like
how high the skill ceiling in this game
can be now they'll also be like
hey if there's three peaking and this
that and the other we're gonna shift and
just like
wait out the thing or like there's
things but like in a
decent point like when the game's like
you know decently balanced or they're
playing a good strategy
it's kind of amazing to watch i just had
to shout that out because that was a
cool experience i was lucky enough to
play
aries has already been like awesome and
backpack but then you put aries and cami
together
like those two like playing off each
other i
i was just along for the ride and i had
but it was like it was
a very very cool ride to be on yeah it's
good good to see you indeed brother
i'm very proud of you and what i like is
again when the loot is worth it
right and you get you have in-game
content with high
rewarding loot and they made enough
balance so that for the people who were
not going to get the three wins
all the way they ca by just playing the
card you at least had a shot
at the weapon but i gotta ask dan did
you jump in there dan did you do you
have messenger where are you at with it
i am not the biggest pvp guy okay so i
haven't i haven't jumped into
uh trials yeah i haven't jumped into any
any pvp i think i jumped into i jumped
into mayhem last week just to get the
the completion on the um
on the seasonal challenge yeah i wanted
to do that next time it comes around i
did not quite finish mine it was like
five games
like for me it was five games with
hammer titan just yep
memeing around but uh yeah i haven't i
haven't really
popped into pvp all that much just like
the time that i have
to play it on stream got you i usually
end up
brought just running for pvp stuff and
or pve stuff
and so i did get a palindrome this week
um
okay okay i don't know about the roll
but it's uh
it has a corkscrew rifling ricochet
rounds
uh subsistence and rangefinder okay so
it's it's a palindrome in name right day
but there you go
but let me i just want to back up i get
we were out with the pvp i guess i was
curious
that messenger didn't sway you as a 340
with the desperado
to get it even with the the the bounty
that just says hey just play
you know about a certain round i mean it
got to the point i don't know what
they're gonna do about this e
but i saw something with a couple of
teams that i know don't play pvp
and as soon as the match started they
jumped off the map oh yeah no let's see
the bounty that's yeah that's all yep
just the bounty
yeah i don't know it's just like
i don't it's just not on my radar right
now
like collections later like later on in
the season
probably that desperado didn't intrigue
you yet okay
okay i mean i was like the bounty is
like i would i would recommend like
it may not be the best you may get
paired up against crazy skilled people
and
believe me it's like me if i jumped in
with like me my brother and somebody
else like
we would probably lose every single
match so i was like but
you don't it's completions like it's
just going to take you longer but it's
completions yeah
you'll eventually get the bounty now do
you need to get tokens for even losing
100 because that whole setup is poor
but you get nothing for losing yeah
absolutely nothing
yeah so that needs fix but yeah the
bounty is at least trying for a couple
of these because i don't know if any of
you guys saw us in nomads video
on the hand cannon what do you say what
do you say that hand cannon coming from
trials like when inferno
can't even remember what it's called
igneous igneous igneous yeah
uh can is a 120
that can roll with 100 range
okay so
just just to throw that out there is 120
seem to be kind of meta
however this week like no it was i think
it's weapon
armor weapon armor and a depth mod so
like this weekend won't be quite as
this igneous hammer there you go thank
you um
yes but yeah he was he was messing
around with d2 gunsmith and i was like i
did it as well you can get
yeah either 96 or if you mess some other
stuff around you can get a hundred
depending on what your like give and
takes and stability and stuff are but
literally by only losing about
four handling you can have 96 range
and its base stats are still better than
just about everything else
so if you like 120s at all
like pay attention to when trials
weapons start dropping especially when
it's the bounty
yeah that will be a good time for you to
go get that yeah no i like i just
terrible 120.
forever i just don't have that accuracy
that these guys have
especially at long ranges i'm getting
clipped i'm just like
it's like it's just well and that's the
reason why some people and again i'm
terrible with like dead man's tail in
pvp but some people like it because it
kind of is a
scout hand cannon it hits hard like it's
yeah i actually really like the iron
sight on it
yeah the side's actually pretty clean
very slick
i can't wait
because it's a 120 scout no it's
it's oh it's a one it's a wait a 120
scout yeah
that's slow that's exactly yeah
yeah um gotta hit like a truck then
i took it into uh based on like i think
on reddit
i saw i saw somebody say hey take that
into the xo challenge this week it's
like a shooting gallery and it is
it is 100 of shooting gallery it's
really
like yeah it hits 84 to the head
and then you start stacking it when i
think it's three
and like your third and fourth sec you
can start two tapping
like i've seen like the high skilled
people just like throw videos of it's
just
lethal yeah i gotta check it out yeah
it's it's a unique one for sure
oh no doubt uh so yeah nothing else
happened no other big announcements or
anything
zero uh that's another week guys that's
it for the
week for bungie you wanna you wanna say
you wanna take this one there cog what
what did they
drop news wise to us on it was thursday
yeah it was yesterday morning thursday
so yeah it looked like a major um
it's not the tassie he put it to my
attention um
they had their own post and i believe
shout out the game industry.biz
as well so yeah bungie looks like uh you
know all is not
as bad as some half think of this
quote-unquote dead game
oh who's gonna say is this a dead game i
know the opening
amsterdam publishing office you know the
studios doubling the size of the
bellevue washington head headquarters
adding two board members planning
multiple teams and a new ip
now we knew about that ip most likely
matter they said that bungie
get uh beyond push beyond the destiny
universe they plan to launch that new ip
to market before 2025.
they talked about obviously the
expansion with the headquarters the
expansion and staff
you know supporting multiple project
teams including those outside of the
destiny universe
they even hinted at i guess marking a
publishing house obviously i understand
but also from a marketing standpoint
even outside of gaming
and um
yeah so um yeah you know obviously they
looked at the
those two new names was it trace harris
pamela
kaufman and that one has been a senior
vice president and strategy
the big thing about her is where is she
from right
and then yeah viacom yes
yeah you know what i'm saying so that's
100 like film
because it's like nickelodeon mtv comedy
central that's if you have somebody like
that as now are they board members right
mm-hmm
yeah they're bor you bring somebody for
like you know
television and film production into your
board has to be a reason for that
theoretically yeah yeah so that these
are signs
clearly they have plans you know for
destiny and then i just you know bring
it to you guys like what do you guys
think obviously
you know my thoughts are i've been on
the side of
i knew they were doing better than a lot
of people
thought they were because i know the
hardcore is the very loud
minority and when they are not happy
they
necessarily assume that you know things
are not going well
but again being that i was you know
telling he you know i've been on i've
been i was on pc initially and then i
went
back to our console i've been on xbox
i've been seeing the tremendous growth
this is the most my clan has been
playing
i know i live in eververse store every
to every day and you know you start to
see
a lot of these purchases and stuff that
people making but it goes to show that
it looks like things are doing
way better than people anticipated so
what do you think danfinity with all
this news coming out
like how do you feel now about the
future of destiny and how excited
are you about this news i mean i've been
excited about it since they left
activision
um there have definitely been some like
moments where
where you're looking at a season and
been like
i don't know i don't know about this one
this ain't chief but with
like with everything going on here what
season of the chosen
to me is is one of the high watermark
seasons of destiny 2. and then seeing
this come out of that as well
it looks like they've got they're going
to have their hands full for quite a
while i think it means a lot of good
things for destiny
past lightfall um yes good point
good and i just i don't know i
i'm very excited about it especially can
you imagine
like if mega magwitch got the uh green
light
to do destiny cops for comedy central
[Laughter]
the potential is there they got a lot of
potential yeah
a lot of attention yeah it's it's
i i could we've already seen them do
comic books
of the war and or of bridge gap
stories um i could see like more of that
tying in
they definitely have the capital to get
that go
rolling and especially with a new i a
new ip coming
as well yeah bomb death from the makers
of halo and destiny that's
always an exciting thing so hashtag
uh sunset luke smith right that's it
we gonna keep it trending but that's
what that's what the mass is what hold
on
yeah that's stop well yeah
so you go after somebody's job i don't
know that's correct
well it is interesting when you look at
you know to expand the destiny ip and
bring new stories and experience the
highly engaged community bungie
appointed
mark noseworthy vice president and luke
smith executive creative director to the
destiny
universe yeah as opposed to
games so there's the universe as well
universe
yeah it's like they manage the cannon
like they manage all of that at this
point and then justin truman if you guys
have seen him in the vitox before he's
been in plenty
he is now general manager of destiny and
i would imagine
assistant game director or maybe game
director now with promotion
joe blackburn blackburn probably seems
like the natural progression
yeah yeah and that is that would make
sense
to tempt him back like because he left
and then came back
exactly i wondered what did that for him
yeah
um but yeah it's like the big i mean as
of this point especially it's like even
more now i'm very curious to know what
the state of destiny
coming from joe is going to be because
whether it's him or justin i'm not
entirely sure who's going to write it
but
it's very interesting to see what is in
that article now like
how much of the future do they talk
about do that
like i'm so curious to read that even
more now seeing all of this
because you're like hey you could do i
mean easiest thing you could do as an
anime
right mm-hmm yes cheapest thing you
could do
cheapest as well would be i mean you
already got voice actors they can do
those from anywhere
you've got you know tons of stories to
tell between all
the lore um i hope they give some shout
out to like
bife somewhere in all of the production
yeah
um like if they get you know gamma
trapped to do some like
thumbnail covers or like episodes or
just like
i want them to just use a little bit of
the community that has done so much
already to like give some of these
stories life and why you would be
interested to watch them in the first
place because
a lot of people don't know much about
those lores it is and they just go
what's wife's explanation for the video
for the lord because he's gonna do it
better
i hope they give a little bit of credit
to
not saying the writers a bunch he didn't
do anything they did they built it
but some people turned around and take
what took that they built and they gave
it life
on their own so i hope they give them a
little bit of a nod somehow
i don't know if it'll happen but it
would be nice if it did
absolutely yeah i mean again you know
for me
obviously we've been talking about it
you know my always concern
was resources you know my my thing is
i'm always about
getting the most bodies on a project and
if you know the only thing
i had wrong was i did i thought matter
was closer to development so i i was
thinking
mata was going to be right after
lightfall
and at that point we didn't know what
not going to say the
history of destiny was going to in a
flux you know but you know
maybe they transition there and the
resources are now there
we know certain people the team was
split so now that the news is coming out
and it's like
yo they've got all this capital
clearly destiny is doing well and then i
start thinking about the netease deal i
think i start thinking about the bag
they took from stadia i started thinking
about the bag they took from microsoft
for game pass
like these are big bags you know what
i'm saying that they've been
stacking and it's good to see that i
feel good for them as a studio because
let's be real bungee
their history is probably like if you
wrote a book on but like this
is the wildest most unique story from a
development studio i have ever seen
to be part underneath microsoft not on
your ip not on anything
you know what i'm saying being forced to
kind of like crack out halo games
right to being unhappy leaving right
then you're like okay i'm on my own big
activision got me
the deal connor is more contentious than
you know
it was they want them to churn out
there's a bit of a fallout later it was
successful but it was a
yeah it was it was a cadence that bungie
could wasn't comfortable dealing with
and activision wanted more money so then
they leave so now you're like okay
what's the state now that they've lost
all the resources from activision
honeymoon studios vicarious as much as
people don't like activision those
resources helped
right so now they're on their own we
kind of start transitioning into the
seasonal model
now we're like don't know how this is
gonna work
what's the future is it okay and that's
where the questions happen
so it's good to see that you know behind
the hood
they were doing well they were making
money
you know destiny is profitable if you
look at engagement
besides pvp because bbp
you know what to do and again like not
to interrupt
but it's like that is that's still the
question knows like somebody said it in
chat it's like it is interesting
still with all of these resources like
they're to come it's like
what they're planning now you're you are
looking out to lightfall to see the
fruit of this because they're still
yes tight on resources trying to split
things in some like couple places like
they are
they're hiring they're hot they're like
they're 100
and again they're going to take quarters
of like a sub 100 000 square foot to be
even more so it's going to happen yeah
two points
big dammit they
right now that that you don't make those
kind of moves unless the check
book look good unless the account got an
extra couple zeros
in the savings like things are looking
good when they're going to the atm
so again it just takes time to ramp it
up is all i'm saying yes
they have the money they're making the
investment their future plans are
looking very very bright but you can't
expect like which queen is going to be
forsaken
it's not going to be that fast they've
already said the precedence absolutely
that we
this is all gonna take time the thing
that's good about it is
for those who will worry right for those
who are like hey
what's the future of this game you know
now you can
kind of breathe a little bit that they
plan on sticking with this thing they
have big plans for this thing
is everything guaranteed success no they
still have to execute they should have
to do what they got to do
but it is a moment for bungie you know
that that definitely the future is
bright and they're looking to be one of
those
top publishers so the last thing i said
cause my microsoft goes like what do you
think now
and i said look i told my xbox guys look
i don't think it's happening now and as
far as microsoft acquisitions because
microsoft is in this acquisition phase
and the reason why i say that
is look can they throw a bag at them yes
but the the
the issue comes down to you know when
you start opening up a publishing
place an abstinence you're looking to
stand on your own you're looking to be
the next blizzard the next you know old
bioware
and stand on your own too and now
they've got the strength to do it you
know what i'm saying so
it appears so so that's what i feel and
i think that i told myself i think what
it'll be
the relationship will always be great
between those two because they're
definitely phil and peter like peas of
the pod
people phil spencer and pete parsons you
know what i'm saying so i think that'll
be good they'll probably have those
little sweetheart deals
where you know it'll come in game pass
and stuff like that but it'll be
them at most a partnership with certain
little deals
as opposed to oh they're buying them now
because this move to me
denotes standing independence creating
your own
wealth your own you know i'm saying
ecosystem so that's just where i'm at
with it but it was it was good it was
surprising and good to see at the same
time
yeah i concur
what would you guys like i've seen some
ideas in chat like what stories would
you like to see
them tell how would you like to see it
told
i saw a hilarious one in chat that i'll
bring up in a second but if they do
branch out into
tv or movies or both like
what stories would you like to see told
from
just this universe because now we truly
have a destiny universe
in like titles do you want what you want
man
uh i i think the origins of the awoken
would be an interesting series
also apparently very dark from what
we've learned this year yeah
so i like i don't know i
it kind of fits in with what's going on
like art wise
so i don't know like that would be cool
it would it would be interesting to see
maybe i just like dark stuff i don't
know yes
i mean it's usually interesting so it's
fair yeah like the stories of the first
fire teams that go into vault of glass
or
um or curtis end aeris fire team
yeah oh quota story would be crazy could
you imagine like that's like
the end of the horror film oh that's a
horror film yeah
the end of that is just aris like
crawling her way out and like that's the
end of the
best show she's the last girl she's the
final girl
in any horror movie they need a final
girl and like she would be
sure shout out to black iron man six
fronts twilight
cat battle twilight gap those are some
really epic
battles in destiny history where they
were kind of on the precipice of defeat
the fallen was overwhelming them and
then uh you know the the
titan gang you know shout out to shax
and i'm turning the tide you know
so uh yeah listen it's the last word
which was
yeah that's a great one shin malfur all
that he does like they got stories
they got stories he's just gonna be the
format you know
how they choose to do it but um it's
cool man listen
we know right now especially with the
pandemic that
you know video game stories right now
they used to be like a cliche like a
stigma back in the day like don't know
video game
story you know saying like like you know
like the movie to a video game would
always be terrible back in the day
yeah but that stick was going down like
you got you got things like the witcher
you got you know what i'm saying you got
things slowly starting to change around
where
i guess the movie business i feel is
kind of like investing
a little bit more in gaming in it what
do you think what do you guys think do
you think it's a
a little bit better climate now or you
think not so much i mean you got monster
hunter last year
okay all right there you go there you go
spoiling it
uh you have the witcher and you have
monster hunter in about the same
12-month period and those are about as
far apart
of quality as what you would want like
the witcher is
excellently well done good story great
adaptation given the budget given the
quality it needs
and then you have monster hunter and i
was like i worried about from when i saw
the title card much less
i'm like you could do that so much
better but again like
was that paul s anderson more power too
you're making plenty of money so good
for you
um paul anderson i don't like to see
movies
but on the other side it's just like for
me i think
it's got potential like also people are
like the assassin's creed movie
with like michael fassbender even good
cow like michael fassbender is an
amazing actor
yeah right unfortunately it's like
people are like that movie tanks
people have to eat people have to pay
the bills you're not gonna be in a good
movie every time
yeah i mean yeah no but i was just gonna
say it's like
so there's a lot of pieces that have to
come together for it to do well you have
to have a good script you still gotta
have good marketing it's gotta hit the
right audience and i think
for them especially if before they ever
did a movie or live action i think an
anime would be the cheapest best place
to start to build it
yeah and then like if you get enough
then maybe a netflix like live-action
series if you get enough
and get people to somehow act that thing
if you don't have lance ericka zavala i
don't know what you're doing
yeah like he has to be there so it's
like there's certain people
he had a little petition for herself a
little tweet to herself
and then it's like then could you like
do a culmination of a movie to make
something bigger and grander for a
finale
that type of stuff would be cool to see
them build but if they just like
try and do a destiny movie i think it
would flop pretty hard because you don't
yeah there's a lot of people who play
the game but you know a few million
people who play the game
may have heard of it may have seen it's
not enough to like make that production
budget pay for itself so
i think you would have to start small
and build yeah yeah yeah
almost like a like a destiny clone wars
kind of deal oh i could yeah i would
watch
that to see like stories go through or
like how they do seasons to sell whether
it's like mini series for characters
even if they did almost the marvel um
marvel netflix
marvel netflix set up like explain some
characters and then have them come
together for like
the battle at six fronts like special or
the way they did the cw
and they had to like the combat like
everybody come together for like
arrow and flash come together for like a
set number of episodes and then split
like those would be cool because you
could have like the stories of zavala
you could have the stories of like
what the hell is osiris been doing
forever like you'd love that like
yup oh man grounded individual stories
where it's your character build
and then you kind of you can kind of
defenders them or later you don't say
that bring them in
you know avenge your style later but you
you flesh out the universe from a one
character perspective
and um yeah that's that's a lot of
potential i would love to know the
stories of kade
yeah yeah kate's got a lot kate's got a
lot that's a gold mine right there let's
be real
yeah they're sitting on that's a gold
mine they even get you they could call
your boy back up baby
yeah call your boy you know rookie's
still out there but you know yeah
got to do something man she's been
chilling yeah for a while she is not
involved in this
you know yeah she's chilling yeah but
hopefully at the end
there's comic book series too like we've
talked about that yes yes
yes they could easily do like a
comicology exclusive digital only book
fold that into physical books that they
sell in their shop or whatever oh yeah
so there's all sorts of stuff that they
can do with it
possibilities are there and what's
interesting is obviously when we see
these new board members we know this is
a direction they will definitely
be broaching they'll be definitely
looking into it you know saying so
yeah good for them good for them on the
expansion and see the future looks
bright
team uh and then we had the shortest
swab ever
yes you got a new mission iron banners
next week we out
that was mostly it like iron banner
comes back
yeah we got new gun no new old guns yeah
re-reverse yeah it was like refurbs yeah
all right
refurb refresh reissue but yeah you got
the uh multi-mock ccx and then you've
got the timeline
what it was so bad i didn't remember it
no all the time both of these are like
from
red war they're oh geez like for destiny
yeah because i looked back through
because i was looking for new guns i
didn't have yet in the collections and
was like oh yes and then i was like wait
is there another one of these and i had
to like
yep that name exists that name they
already exist what's the top what was
the
rpm on the tom warren spire i couldn't
tell you what time i had
i don't think you think it's a 450 i
think it's uh
i don't think what i don't think it's a
it's not a
hard hitting one not a slow it's not
like a messenger style
i don't think crystal science 40 okay
540 crystal okay 540. okay
that's kind of vigilance that's
vigilance territory that'll be nice it's
kind of still nice
there's also going to be a new perk
added in yes
yeah okay okay and it's like it greatly
increased range of the trade-off of
stability as they just lowered stability
for
yeah granted i will say i haven't felt
it too much
um it hasn't been that drastic
i think i've heard some people say is
like if you really focused on it you
could notice some things
and it's like there's probably a little
bit of like little harder to control
feel at times that i notice
um overall it's not drastic it's not
like i'm
facing the ceiling or anything so that's
fair uh
i will say though some of these like
the give and take perks yeah i'm not a
fan
i'm not a fan not a fan i was like just
like
iron reach massively increased range
maybe these two weapons don't get high
stability like range in the first place
so they don't get high stability
so you know from that like that but like
just if you get this perk and then you
like the reload speed is awful
if you get the one where it's like
stability for reload speed you have like
eight or five or whatever this really
tiny single digit number
probably is really bad yeah i was like
and then yeah you do get a lot of
stability but you're like oh it's going
to take me an hour to reload hold on
let me look at my magazine one bullet at
a time come on where's the magazine
[Laughter]
um i just i don't know the give and take
on like the fragments as well it's like
i wish
they could just let us be that little
bit extra powerful
like yeah not the give and take
especially when it comes to stats they
don't matter that much in the first
place
so when you're like oh here's this minus
10 strength i'm like why does my
artifact or my class item has zero
strength on it
because one of the mods that i have on
there always takes away strength and i
don't even forget about it but
yeah it's just always a little weird
that everything's now gonna be give and
take like
are we really bumping up against that
power creep wall that hard
yeah i don't know they yeah
they still policing out here they're
still police with these
very extreme perks with extreme penalty
kind of deal even with
a lot of the um what you call it the uh
adept mods of like that nightfall
version
stuff these i would understand more than
those depth should not have any give and
take
i'm sorry that i think is especially for
the work that you have to go through the
work that you have to do yet
those should be just better yeah
yeah i gotta i gotta i gotta agree i
gotta
anybody have you been lucky enough to
get um
well you got pilot drone but not the
greatest role right i haven't got either
yet
you haven't got shadow price either nope
no shadow press no no no no i didn't get
shadow price
and i'm i think i'm the only person in
here that has bottom dollar
probably i have one oh you didn't get
one since we last
uh where is that stupid thing too i also
got the gambit fusion
that's not anything to be expected
did you get the crucible sniper i got
that one too no
i have not i got the third axiom which i
guess is like the vanguard pulse
i got that one where is my bottom dollar
oh there it is uh oh it's subsistence
rampage
okay like subsistence on certain guns is
okay but some systems on the hand cannon
you have like 70 bullets
like six clips and you're out and i was
like crap so i was like it
it i didn't notice as much until i was
actually running low on primaries like
oh
because auto rifles you don't feel it
nearly as bad you still got hundreds of
bullets but like that one's like uh
that's a problem so rampage overall not
too bad
man it kicks hard though bottom down
yeah
yeah definitely definitely i got that i
got a
outlaw dragonfly something yeah
i like that though dragonfly is not bad
no it's not bad
for the right case i was dragonfly is
like the one where i always picture
because dragonfly is how i finished
uh shatter throne yeah cause every time
you spawn the ads on each side it was
grenade on one side dragonfly on the
other clear
nice and then just okay yeah i was like
those were good
and then yeah so i don't know i'll have
to toy with it and see but
overall i finished my catalyst for i'm
working on the the kills for tiku's
divination
yeah absolutely um so i got those
working on
and then we there's a rumor of what the
catalyst is for
uh exotic quest gun but i'll let you get
the gun first before we talk about it
we don't need to spoil that one yeah
trying to think of anything else i got
salvager salvo finally finished that one
up
so here's a question
how does the rest of the season look for
you guys
ego is his captain clean the question
oh my god no no it's really like man
just had a full course meal we talked
about that before
we i would say what i said you got the
same line you're not even crazy
because the fans are here
did not hear our pre-k fire talk this
man
he's laughing he's laughing this man got
a
full course meal he's fresh off of
wiping his face
of dead man's tail which he didn't
expect
and already is wanting to look at the
menu
and what more food he is going to
consume
after his greedy self just had this
amazing cut this is this is what
these are these hardcore destiny players
the bungie this is what we're talking
about
they're unappreciative you give them
this great stuff
and they're back at the table asking for
more look the rest of the season doesn't
look all
the that is yours dad how are you
feeling sir
we're looking at so i'm i'm i'm
refreshing on this real quick
so we have the oracle battleground next
week with iron banner
and then a full month after that proving
grounds the
the new strike opens up for season pass
holders
and iron banner
[Laughter]
i don't know an appreciative guardian
i'm of two minds i feel like they front
loaded this season
yes a lot just to get the stuff
out for you to do okay now how
enticing that's gonna be later on in the
season
i don't know but i think that's also why
they built in
the season the seasonal challenges the
way that they did the way that you can
if you if you want to take a break and
take a couple weeks off and play i don't
know
like borderlands or like something else
yeah uh haiti like if you want to play
anything else
they've built they've kind of built into
their system that you can leave
and come back and earn just as much as
if you had previously it's got to be a
little bit more of a grind
but maybe that's what you're looking for
after that time off
so for me like i'm looking forward to a
new strike
like a new new strike yeah um
i when it comes to guardian games
i'm not a fan i'm with you
yeah especially like and so this thing
just a slight sting to my wounds this is
the last season
i did i did a charity drive last year
where one of the goals
was for me to be a two-season titan i
don't like being on titan
i don't i'm a hunter maine yeah
this is my last season as a titan and
they're going to throw guardian games in
there
oh yeah we're in trouble i'm taking it
i'm taking it
thank you throwing it
[Music]
that's it i feel you i listen we got to
see we got to see um
definitely i will say this i'm a little
bit
more optimistic only for one reason
they could have easily put dead man's
tail at the end of the middle of the end
of the season
easily and we would have been okay we
would have sorted the time gate stuff
that we're already dealing with
we saw the battleground ground stuff we
saw the hammer stuff
and then they would have stuck it in
towards the end oh my god budget is what
i'm talking about
so to me i almost i don't get too much i
almost feel like they got
something else why throw this so
early like what are we week two
three what what are we in season and
chosen where are we yeah
yeah like week two we too
i've never seen a week two
special mission so again
i'm i'm not gonna get crazy you know we
know they're gonna be ramping up
we know you know they're still gonna
grow but that's not happening overnight
you know what i'm saying so you know i'm
keeping expectations and yes i'm with
you then
i see guardian games and i roll my eyes
especially because i know most likely
ain't gonna be no srl there's gonna be
nothing that the fans
want i'm with e on that i see where he's
going
right oh and i want to give him a little
hope though because i'm like
i was like i just got a lot of crap
about 60 seconds ago so continue
just gave him that mission that he could
have
easily had at the mid to the end of the
season
so that to me gives me a little hope
they've never really done that but it's
got random roles so i think they're
gonna want you to grind it this season
right right you definitely don't go back
in there you know saying that that's the
whole thing to go back in
but they can't expect that to they can't
say finished
done all right that's just that's just
me i i can't say because even with last
season
that type of thing was hot moon towards
the middle
there's a mess there's a master
difficulty coming
right absolutely absolutely so we're not
getting
we're not getting a second exotic quest
this season
right but do you think master difficulty
is
going they're going to spawn that toy
you they're going to hold that off the
very very
end where do you think that timing of
that is coming i don't want to say it
too much because i saw a date of mine
spreadsheet of
dates of things but my hunch it is it is
the time we thought
it was going to start in the first place
got you towards the end
mid to later two-thirds that general
time
where you expect it where things are
slowing down
that's probably where your other like
can you roll your other ones okay
now okay kick it up a notch give people
time to level up
crank up the difficulty see where it
goes from there it's already hard
it says 12 30 but i was like 12 30 my
butt yeah
it doesn't matter what level you are
it's always going to hurt so
like i don't know what the delta on the
master is going to be
because if the delta's like 10 now then
it's going to be just painful later
right shout out to don't master truth we
definitely um
didn't get the catalyst and does it have
a catalyst open slot
yep gonna have a catalyst so they could
definitely do what they did with
hortmoon
right where the second variation of the
mission or whatever
you got that okay okay look we got to
see we got to see um
i definitely hear what you're saying
that's the only reason why i'm hoping a
little hope
and what i'm saying is that's like oh
you we're going to get a dungeon now i'm
not i'm not going
okay you know like i i'm keeping it
expectations in check i think a smaller
surprise
you know i that's what i'm about that's
what i'm thinking something smaller on a
smaller end
whether it be narratively look at them
look it up no no you said the one word i
thought maybe narratively
that's alternatively okay yeah it's like
if there's
a story beat something cool that drops
with like the war table and kaido
because there's the cut scene again okay
so when it comes to cut scenes
invite in preview videos like the
season of the chosen video we've seen
the video
now of crow standing behind zavala the
chest in the middle the scion and then
they're on the other side
spoiler spoilers yeah can you not
stop yesterday can you not tell us like
the end of the season at the beginning
because they've been waiting for it the
whole time whether or not you're like
eight weeks in you finish up you know
you drop these things well here's the
new like cinematic for the week cool
we also saw part of that before the
season came out
don't you know i'm what you don't you
know what you do you know i'm what you
did
that is sadly we're gonna lose
to the marketing team we're gonna lose i
think you can still have everything they
did in the marketing team without
showing me that's
because it's like yeah five seconds i
agree that's not necessary because
like you could have shown like gameplay
you could have shown a lot of stuff
early in the scene anything else
basically
without showing what that is because if
we're this far into the season
couple weeks seen the initial stuff we
kind of know how this goes
for a cinematic related to anything
right battlegrounds or
kaitlyn or whenever that piece comes in
six seven eight weeks later
we don't need to see anything related to
that to start because at some point now
that's all we're waiting on that's the
issue
of a thousand percent with you you know
i'm with you but i don't
know why marketing says they have to put
that in there because that just breaks
the story
like you can have anticipation of more
stuff
but you can show plenty in that little
trailer without having that in there
that trailer has the same hit
you take that out it feels the same know
how they are with data
analytics and they go because we showed
can you getting smoke now you're going
to want to play
[Laughter]
but what they showed doesn't change
anything i'm with you brother
i know i'm
listens to this i just want to be like
save that stuff for the actual drop
that's all right i just like to say i
love it i love the surprise of not
knowing i love that aspect you know and
to me
i agree we should not be seeing you know
crow
and and zavala meeting up with kato
somewhere and
we seeing that you know what i'm saying
in any capacity i i'm with you
they are not listening to that or what
did we've been screaming this for the
mountaintops
forever since forsaken we mean you was
like yeah they should not have showed
yeah
they cater it would have been harder if
you didn't know
kate was gonna pass right but someone's
in marketing
is telling someone in narrative team yo
you know to be hot
if we showed it like that's what's going
on and they're like
okay we've relinquished linquish this
scene to you like that's
clearly marketing is winning this battle
because i
i'm with you like why is narrative
giving this stuff up to them
to put in a trailer because now like you
said e
we're now wait it's like last season i'm
waiting for the scene
to see the cabal behind osiris and
zavala to go
meet cattle for the title for the first
time it would have hit
harder if we didn't see that and then
it's you know what i'm saying
what's up that's right if that's at the
end of the season i'm sorry
yeah that's got to stop anyway sorry dan
what do you mean
it's kind of like when you're when
you're watching a movie
and then a character says the title of
the movie
[Laughter]
and you're like oh he said the thing and
it takes your emotion out
i was literally watching the equalizer i
was watching the equalizer with my wife
the new queen latifah show
and it's the end of the second episode
they squeezed it and i was like oh i see
how you shoehorn that it like
it feels forced sometimes especially
when you're like what the
what they call you and just like the
equalizer and i'm like
you had to do it that way
did you give yourself that nickname
clearly we're not fans of this this
level of marketing here
of which i'm with y'all you know it's
just
someone up top just does not agree with
us yeah we keep losing this fight
but we're going to keep championing
we're going to fight for it
i'm just i guess in that
in that view i guess i'm glad that they
didn't show us more
of glycon before
like they showed us kind of like the
perfect they did a little
see that that was okay yeah
because that gave me hope of what it
could be and they actually followed
through on expectations
but on the other side yes like
when they show something especially if
it's the season end or again i'm like
this is a pattern that'll be a pattern
that i hope stops
because like i don't need to see the
book end of the story
in the start in this thought yeah like
let me let me go through the middle
because like when you set up the war
table and you
like see as you said osiris talking to
kaido like talk to zavala like
we can work through this and it's like
have you seen what we've done like they
go through all of those pieces i'm like
those are awesome to get through because
you're seeing kaidal is more
strategic not just like i'm in i'm just
a crazy cabal and i want all the power
it's like
no it's like the darkness is here the
hive are a problem we know those are an
issue
i need the guardians but i was like she
wants them as like to mel but also she's
not dumb enough she's not dumb she's
still going to ask because what is it if
you don't ask you don't get it
you don't get it but now that she's
asked she's like well now we got to see
how the
how everything plays out but she's not
ready to just like screw you we're going
to war
because either way you got the big
looming darkness on the
you know outer rim right so it's cool to
watch all of this transpire like go
listen to the radio i think it was new
rad and chat go listen to
the radio in the helm because you have
like the postmaster and your vault
go listen to those like go in there
everyone's like listen to all that stuff
it's awesome in there
awesome and i'm loving that type of
stuff too and
i love our little treehouse yes
it's phenomenal that that's why i love
this season so much
i'm getting the narrative beats from
destiny that i've always wanted
and it's not always about spending big
money on
big cinematic show pieces of follow
doing this and
like that's cool but you can still world
build
by doing this stuff that they're doing
right here and i i love it
yeah that that's the way that that is
the way men lauren go that that is the
way
that we need these is the way get the
quotes
oh here we go correct captain correction
here
anyway i finally figured out how to
pronounce the mission but how do you
guys pronounce it because i know
definitely i was saying it slightly
wrong
what what how do you pronounce the
exotic mission because i had looked it
up this morning i was curious
i call it glycon but that's
i don't know well pre-sage is what i had
been saying because i was like is it
pre-saved but yeah you actually had it
presage
so it's presager pursuit presage
presage or presage either one of those
but yeah it's like you want to know what
i looked up what that means too
something something that foreshadows or
portends
a future event an omen
um or to give an omen of warning to
foreshadow or to predict
now when it comes to like the end of
that and i don't want to do it until you
play it
go look up some of the tweets about what
people found in there
when you play that mission
now you may not find it because it's not
the easiest thing to find but go look up
stuff about that after you play it
and then we'll talk a little bit more
next week once you've had a chance to
kind of digest because i want you to dig
into
a couple pieces that are in that mission
about what's going on because new rad
had me like send me the tweet and stuff
like that
um yeah he's always on top of it and
so go dig into that because it's just
really interesting to know
kind of all the stuff they're playing
with that's all i don't want to say too
much because you haven't played it but
the ending is there's more in that room
and then if you don't find it go dig
into
what other people found for me just to
conclude i know which
last question is just that i know the
concern with the content i get it
you know if they can if they could
somehow continue
this narrative cadence and keep on tying
things and then the new battleground i
knew that now we know when guardian
games ain't much they're going to save
no law can say that
but you know if they continue that i
think
they're on point for a solid season to
figure out and then
transition that bad boy smoothly into
the next season and somehow
figure out a way to get me to my vaulted
glass in a cool
fashion for the summer yeah and you got
me so they
they the playbook that play is there is
ready just to be executed
and i'm ready to give caesar to chosen
that you know that one of those
titles is one of the best seasons so far
but they've got to execute the only
thing i'm worried about
i just want to i want to know where
you're going to rank this thing come
april
yeah we'll see we'll see i'll be right
now like right now like it be
it's hitting all the hangers right now
to start yeah but we're two weeks
in and you have a 13 week if a week one
two three
and then like you're on week nine ten
eleven and you're like facts
no no that's in the next part like
absolutely if it gets to that point
then it's the idea of like it's it's
never going to be easy to pace one of
these seasons and i get that
right and honestly part of me is like
i'm and this is where i'm going to play
my the other side of
like myself too it's like part of for
one outriders is coming
i'm looking forward to playing that and
having time to which is like you know if
there's downtime
i'm 100 okay with this um but on the
other side is
it's the quote from the diablo
developers like if people do step away
make sure they step away happy
if people knock out all the stuff in the
beginning three or four hence why the
time getting of the hammer
kind of irks me a little bit if that's
not in there this feels a little better
but the seasonal challenge is
it's kind of a mix but again if it
starts strong people step away do other
stuff
and then come back wrap up the seasonal
challenges get to the next season
and it kind of it's okay with the break
in the middle that might actually work
right and that may be what they built is
like three solid weeks of here's all
your battlegrounds strike in the middle
right and then guardian games the kind
of seasonal thing to wrap it up and
throw some eververse out there to pay
for the new studio
and then like and then you rap into
into the story whatever that does you
come back after doing other things
that honestly may be what they're trying
to do
and it's like if you give me all the
bangers in the beginning take a little
break last few weeks i come back knock
out all my challenges that i can make up
for
that actually is probably gonna feel
almost
better i was like so
but again i'm not saying the middle
might not have a drought in it
yeah i just know i've got something to
look forward to in the middle if
somebody who's like
i want to play this every day and
they're not getting much that again it's
going to depend on the person so
i will be very curious to see how this
plays out with the calendar as is
because i pictured that exotic quest to
be about five weeks from now not now
so it was interestingly timed
yeah we gotta see yeah i would agree i
would agree i think that
i would be fine with that you know
realistically you know that would be
something like i could handle
and then still be able to play other
games if you need to step away if you
know
you got everything you got to get and
then the casual guy he gets to catch up
because obviously he's way behind us
right now you know what i'm saying he's
got to catch up and you know we'll get
in pocket but yeah
i'll be cool with that i'll definitely
record that so
we have had a shout out from kevin
we have had some sit-ups redeemed
oh and kevin was asking if our guest was
going to partake
[Laughter]
so i'm going to let dan and kevin talk
it out and chat so you guys worked that
out i got some stuff to do behind me
um but yeah as we're slowly wrapping up
at this point um
i don't know if there's much else but
sir like dan if you got anything coming
working on all that you guys can talk
i'm gonna go do my thing cognito's gonna
do his thing
yeah my thing is i don't have the setup
to do said thing
that's my thing but you can catch me at
the gym
doing that if you follow my instagram
and my twitter which i do post
off on social media but dad what's up
bro like what you got going on man
uh this is this is the part in the show
where i go oh hey my name is dan finney
we do
i do i'm on twitch three days a week
doing pve activities that's distracting
that's distracting
that's great form sir look at that it's
great keep doing that
that's right that this is a man
performing
executing perfect form during a pandemic
and some without power this is don
this is how you warm yourself up without
power that's how you do it that's how
you do it this is how you do it right
here
let's get that going on we need that
good commentary we got to motivate our
texas guardians
our tax mechanic he's he's our texas
mechanical guardian that's what we call
them today
ibantis hold it down for the state of
texas
giving them that good for look at the
elbows look at the form
look at this this is touching his
temples like he's got the mind read
somebody
he's a machine he's the person
he's the esoteric of sit-ups do you see
this it's just he cannot stop
it it is it is just flawless execution
and a man does not tire i i believe he's
a robot
i believe he's a rope he's an android
he's an exo he's an ex exo exo ibantis
that's
the chat there you go
got the pump going the face is red now
he's ready for the gg
he's ready
when the hair do that and then again
that's when you know it was a good one
let's
look at it in the front part of his head
do that that's when you know
he killed it
[Laughter]
absolutely other than that you can find
me on twitter instagram
[Laughter]
you can find me
your clown plays what up i see you in
there laughing everybody in there
laughing
you know i gotta get that commentary you
know i gotta get that commentary
football boy
the ebons is the exo the esoteric setups
the text mechanica holding down
for the stuff i was giving all type of
superlatives you was lit he was like
when the clock can't come out that's
what you know it's a good workout
yeah that's when the clock comes out
it's lit
that just means i need a haircut
but salute to you there for dealing with
our foolishness
i deal with much worse on a weekly basis
i salute to eve for being a good sport
while be while i commentate
his pain
and one of these times we gotta turn and
flip the camera and be like somebody's
gonna i'm gonna be like make it like
25 000 points so you guys can redeem for
cognito
you can see cognito at the gym on
instagram and twitter
and all that good stuff there
just don't get to set him back he might
just have to he might just have to cash
him in later on
yeah when i visit we gotta see
we do last word from there last word
here two seeds
there we go there we go we're getting in
unison i need another green screen this
one's not wide enough
yes that is correct that is correct no
doubt but yeah man what else is going on
so you got that you know
you got plenty of dusty popping yeah
every sunday
i'm on the podcast planet destiny uh
twitch.tv forward slash play underscore
destiny
uh i release beardo the podcast whenever
i feel like it
uh and yeah
i've just released a new shirt uh from
dr jones
it looks awesome i'm stoked on it
i love this shirt salute to you and i
definitely just catch a little bit of
the beardo
too as well yeah a little unique he's
like i don't know how long it's gonna
last i don't know how long i'm doing it
but this is what it is
so i was like all right i feel the
vision i feel the concept
of marketing yes absolutely salute to
the planet destiny team obviously we had
uh
amazon before now you you know i'm
saying i think we're missing we're
missing a little bit
blacklight yeah
tbl now a big tbl fan too i like y'all
playing the destiny guys you're kind of
cool
yeah put the word out man the last part
tell them come by the car fight it's
nice man
all right i'll see what i can do yeah
man yeah
we're friendly we do i mean i've been
here for two hours and haven't
hated my time hey that's a low bar but
damn that's good
that's good that's good like i've been
here yeah we appreciate
the love and the kind words you son of a
no
i've been here for two hours and not
hated what time is this one time yet
god bless you
[Laughter]
you take what you can get take what you
can get man we'll take it we'll take it
man we'll take it
oh man i can't even follow up with that
one
i'll follow up for me it's better at
lord cogan you know you know what i'm
saying i guess look to dan finney for
coming through
you catch me on twitter and um yeah man
check out the uh
ironwood podcast on sunday 1 p.m eastern
we'll have a developer indie developer
if you're into
um and what is it uh get my animes right
but manga is right
shonen manga shonen manga if you're into
that
and um like comics and anime and then
shout out to my boy the everborn
saga we're gonna have the developer of
this new game coming out it's gonna be
uh
supporting we try to support him check
it out you're going to learn his journey
very very powerful story and very this
guy
he's got a lot of talent so check him
out we'll also be talking about the
latest topics in gaming
with my brother's king david lord
attitude you've seen in here earlier
and lord saw so check us out sundays 1pm
eastern
on the online podcast youtube channel
and then for me uh again appreciate the
support for uh lordsofgaming.net you
guys have been great
just retweeting the articles and
supporting the content we're seeing some
cool growth man we got some special
things planned
there and uh yeah thanks for hanging out
with the last word
man it's a fun show as always the
campfire is always lit
now next week is going to be interesting
because
cognino is going for a surgery so we're
probably not going to have an episode
next week yeah
so far if i do anything it's probably
just going to be me talking about stuff
yeah
so so cog might be out of commission
while the weather where the schneiz gets
fixed
and uh we'll see how that goes but um
yeah thank you for all the love and
see everybody on twitter sending love
and stuff like that so i will let you
guys know how i recover
should be maybe just a week and that's
it but of course my man
e the last word another fantastic
episode brother
and i had to shout you out i don't know
if you saw um we put out the uh
there's like i said we talked about with
luke smith and these guys and you know
why we play destiny and these are the
things they
the relationships the people you meet
you know the play we talked i talked
about iron man podcast how that was
founded initially off of destiny
you know last word obviously you know
founded because of destiny
at gcx formerly destiny con and meeting
people like dan in person at these it's
you know
all this stuff is part of the community
and why we love this game so
you know had to shout about and guess
what your boy got a like
from both pete persons and mark
noseworthy i made it
you're done oh and you already got phil
spencer the other week man
you may you can die happy now you're
good to go
list tweets are checked twitter account
works it now
i've confirmed it does access these
people's accounts also so
absolutely it was cool to see man we
would like to see the support and
everything
yeah man that's what i got yeah i mean
for me you guys know i've been putting
out the guides thank you guys for the
support on the channel those have been
kicking off pretty well uh continuing to
work out you know work on
things uh hopefully the weather calms
down seems like it should so things
should get a little bit more back to
normal
uh as for internet playing every episode
by i'm streaming this thing as low as i
can to make something work so
internet and streaming i'm trying to
stick to the schedule so you guys watch
the twitter make sure you guys know if
the schedule comes out
trying to make sure that thing can work
as long as streaming isn't trash because
it really sucks if you try and stream
too
a trash connection then you guys are
like hey this is
not great it hurts it hurts me to my
very soul so i apologize about that one
uh but thank you guys for all the
support everybody sending out love to
texas thank you guys
um and everybody just out there stay
warm stay safe you guys have all been
awesome if you have you know power and
connection and access to destiny then
great
if you're doing other things then you
know take the breaks you need we got
outrighters demo actually start
next week yeah that will start on the
25th it is
and this i do want to clarify everybody
i know i'm an ambassador and be like oh
what you're doing
no honestly for me it's like if you like
looting
shooting third person got abilities
though
the demo is free there is no end to the
demo
so it's just going to be indefinitely
open until the game starts
and your progress from the demo will
transfer over to your full game
so it's going to be the prologue in the
first chapter
get up to about level seven see the
first boss and
oh you'll have six character slots so
you can mess around with all four
classes
goof around with those there's a lot
that looks actually
promising and guess what you don't have
to pre-order a damn thing
and you can try it for free so that's
honestly like hopefully i haven't played
it yet so again this is all just from
what i've seen
i think it looks like it's going to be
fun it is not a live service game so if
you do buy it there will be an end point
at some point when you get high enough
and strong enough
um so that being said that's probably
going to occupy a decent amount of time
coming up
so it will be mixed of both destiny and
outriders on my channel so probably a
pretty good balance and between that it
seems like uh
immortals phoenix rising maybe on a
little bit of a hiatus until i get back
to it
but i still want to play that if i can
squeeze some in here and there so i will
try and knock some of that stuff out but
between work stay tuned on twitter for
the schedule
i just literally got a text that my work
schedule may change for a few weeks so
we will see
okay um but that's all i got dan man
dude it's been a pleasure i know
yeah like any time i see about like
getting guests on here i swear i reach
out like six months later i finally get
you guys on the show but
it feels like it takes a long time to
get some people on here so thank you for
coming through it was a pleasure man
absolute blast having you on
definitely your pedigree in the
community is like you know
easy to speak for so happy to have you
join us and talk about what was
a pretty awesome week for me anytime we
get these rare missions they are pretty
pretty special heck yeah yeah if you
thanks for having me it's been a
pleasure i know i i know i said i didn't
hate it
i actually love it thank you guys for
having me
absolutely uh well if you're going to
wrap this thing up we are going to go
raid to fizzle
so shout out definitely some pvp and
lots of skill over in that man so watch
him he's playing
this morning uh but for episode number
137
we are wrapping this thing up thank you
guys for tuning in this morning
danfinity
awesome guest cognito stay safe on the
surgery i know we will be off next week
so stay tuned
you guys might get a little uh turn in
for tune in from me whether it be like
whether i grab somebody and do a quick
chat or just do a solo on my own you
guys might see something pop up
probably not as anything like this uh
but other than that one we're gonna wrap
this thing up so
episode 137 february 19th chat you guys
have been fantastic
goes tell go send love to defizzle in
the raid and for everybody here today
thank you very much
it has been the last